you get back to see your family a lot
you get back to uh yeah i want to get
back to boston more i was supposed to go
home for easter but um i'm sort of
terrified of easter because
uh eight years ago i knocked out my two
front teeth during a blindfolded easter
egg hunt
i've never heard of i don't eat tonight
yeah no but easter egg concerts must be
blindfolded well my mother wanted to
like
make it more difficult because we were
all sort of
i was 16 at the time my brother was 19
my sister was 23 so she wanted to make
it more difficult so she decided we'd
all blindfold
ourselves and be paired with like a
member of our family to lead us around
finding eggs
so i was paired with my father and i was
going pretty
well i had a few eggs i was blindfolded
and you're 16 at the time i was 16. yeah
and at one point he says at one point he
says uh yo dude there's an egg at your
feet
and uh there was an egg in my feet and
there was also
a outdoor metal fireplace
and uh yeah i had the same reaction so
you're dead
so you leaned down and what ha i mean
sorry so i knee down my teeth are
gone and then all of a sudden we were
confronted with the actual difficult
version of an easter egg hunt which was
finding my two teeth
in the grass of my yard so everyone's
like on the ground looking for my teeth
my mother's screaming
i'm i just got my braces off like two
weeks before
oh yeah yeah
and uh so we find one of the teeth we
shove it back in my head
uh is that what you're supposed to do
well i later found out that you only
you could just put it in a glass of milk
and it would have survived but
i was glad to take the shoving it in my
head option but uh
so we get to the emergency room there's
like one doctor there who's like my
jewish christ
that wasn't celebrating easter
he um i'm like traumatized he's
operating on me i'm completely conscious
and then all of a sudden he goes uh huh
and the other tooth was involved into my
head
and he pulled it out and uh
yeah so jesus isn't real yeah
yeah no no they actually and then they
actually put the teeth back in my head
they glued
them in place for two weeks i went to
high school with glue and dead teeth in
my mouth
and then they ended up not being able to
save them and they took them out again
and put regular teeth
horrible yeah good thanks mom for like
we got to make this egg hunt more
difficult yeah yeah yeah
well uh now how about just not having an
egg yeah i know
practically adults well we became adults
that day yeah i guess